les enfants sont différents aujourd'hui, j'entends toutes les
mères dire que leur mère a besoin de quelque chose aujourd'hui
pour la calmer et bien qu'elle ne soit pas
vraiment malade, il y a un peu qu'elle va
courir pour abriter le petit assistant de ma mère
et pour aider ses propres enfants
pour la vérité journée bien remplie les
enfants sont différents  Aujourd'hui, j'entends chanter toutes les
mères qui cuisinent de la nourriture fraîche pour son
mari
et elle achète un gâteau instantané
et elle brûle son steak congelé.
Blay
devant la porte, elle le fait pour moi, marche
frite, fais-le obtenir tous les hommes ne sont tout simplement pas
les mêmes aujourd'hui
re le mien alors allez courir pour le
refuge de la petite aide d'une mère et
pour vous aider vrai que je dois le
rencontrer je vole
dr.  jouez un peu plus
j'essaierai de faire le mouton pour bien ce qu'un
amour de disque pourrait stocker aujourd'hui
abri du petit assistant d'une mère,
ils vous aident juste sur votre chemin vers
vous occupé par jour
dr.  Bray
certains sont à l'extérieur de la forme qu'elle a prise,
je veux essayer de tout obtenir